j'avais tout fait mais une image je vous
le dis maintenant les images sont
remises à zéro on va dire que ce nom en
famille bon voisin qui a tourné à
remporter la première session les eaux
non comme ça vous les faites sur msn pas
ici tu verras tu vois et c'est francis
qui va juger
l'image la plus drôle car français c'est
notre invité francis est le taulier
aussi c'est notre patron en 6ieme voix
se font s'ils allaient à ce que cela
nous proposez vos chiens alors moi j'ai
trouvé je pense je pense qu'on pourra
pas vraiment si je vais en premier on
pourra pas là bas trois vidéos d'accord
donc c'est le bois c'est le génie de la
semaine c'est un mec à qui on a demandé
de passer le mot édifices dans une
phrase d'accord et voilà faut regarder
saint-genis est parti et j'ai donné une
phrase où il ya les mots et du fils au
nom du père et du fils fait michel
détruit en mai
t'es sérieux
[Applaudissements]
allez je vote pour cette assez drôle
séquence regarde j'ai capable de donner
une phrase où il ya les mots édifice
renault ni père ni fils émile a détruit
en mai t'es sérieux mais depuis ce matin
[Applaudissements]
on a démarré très fort d'aucun des cases
qui va être dur à détrôner on enchaîne
avec laurence à laurence pérou c'est le
champion de la d'arkham et moi ça va
être le champion de la cradat aller on a
ramé cette personne chez elle alors
allez-y
normalement on dit que quand on marche
dedans ça porte bonheur mais quand on
met le doigt dedans regarde le lancement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je le fais ce week-end salle et moi
c'est une blague à chaque fois que tu
fais chier des gens je suis invité sinon
je vous jure c'est vrai je le fais
jamais toujours avec moi un petit truc
de pâte à tartiner et jodie est-ce que
je peux aller aux toilettes
non mais vous dire que c'est vrai à
chaque fois et ça c'est moi je fais de
la merde allez bernard bocquet alors on
est en plein hiver il ya une jeune femme
qui va travailler comme tout bon frère
tu t'es cru dans faites entrer l'accusé
[Rires]
est en plein hiver non mais là tout à
coup elle croise le chemin
bouchard qui n'avait rien à se reprocher
d'ici là à part quelques petits larcins
il avait volé une renault 19
[Rires]
de fil en aiguille je vous charge de la
laguna de cédric touche alors oui nous
sommes donc en plein hiver je situe
l'action c'est important vous allez
quand il dort que cette jeune femme sort
et tu fume une cigarette et descend un
escalier évidemment se casse la gueule
et manque de pot il ya surfeurs qui
vient à sa rescousse
mais ce n'était pas une bonne idée et
pourtant ce gala animé vidéo gag
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma joie ça tout va pas si mal
l'huile est magique
ça y est ça fait du bien d'avoir des
nouvelles oui super mal c'est bruno qui
est franchement les vidéos sont très
bonnes ce soit meilleur que les
lancements saldana a été bon allez on
n'a pas bien alors moi c'est un hommage
à benjamin castaldi et reynosa quitté
trop tôt ce qui sont tous dans le
registre elles quand elles vont une
image avait donc téléachat lui mais je
pense qu'il s'est mis dans lara sera et
lui frère andré qui est un mort non mais
je fais des hommages pour un hommage à
notre benjamin castaldi vivant
évidemment non non non ben oui c'est
vrai qu'il est mal en france la semaine
c'est le seul divan qui a les yeux
fermés
[Rires]
vous allez voir sur 7 sur 7 d'arc à un
chien qui fait le plus long paix il
existe de l'histoire regardez vous
c'était donc c'est quoi les résumés vous
lancez un chien qui pète à chaque achat
cash
un chien qui pète un chacun on va voir
le sua qui pète le chat qui rote ras
lanouf et c'est parti
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors je pense tous voila je vais perdre
mon titre c'est sûr elle est plus
mignonne que dark à cette vidéo et comme
je suis altruiste j'ai voulu céder ma
place de championne regarder pourquoi
douglas est le meilleur lancement
connais très bien
il revient pour mfm après ça tu lances
ont vraiment eu en salle et tout de
suite
une nouveauté bien entendu
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais elle elle sait pas que cette vidéo
est possible la qualité technique de
marketing s'appelle le pied dans la
bouche ça veut dire qu'en fait elle la
moins value sa vidéo pour comme nous on
est surpris maintenant ça j'appelle le
pied dans la bouche on regarde pas
prendre pied dans la gueule
c'est bien beau
magloire alors qu'on appelle tu veux une
vidéo dark ah oui c'est celle là
excuse moi tu veux c'est un tel bonheur
de vous présenter cette vidéo de mon
cousin est mon cousin on aimerait tous
avant comme cousin comme frère comme ami
il est tellement drôle
allez mayombo je suis fan de ce gars je
vous le dis l'extraordinaire cette vidéo
c'est le mec qui fait le buzz le plus en
ce moment conclut david imposer des
choses et ce même si mayombo regard du
lauquet comme ça qui ne s'est pas fait
les choses à temps
guy ça c'est pas déjà normal tu vois je
vois les retombées se compliquer la vie
[Applaudissements]
grâce à ses séries qu il arrive du gabon
ils arrivent au camp là tout de suite
il est sur le plateau magail
[Applaudissements]
ex époux film et rush comme un ouf de
devoir meghraoui je suis trop content de
moi mais c'est comme moi aussi faire un
bisou moi oui
ça fait trop longtemps que je t'attends
sans rigoler je sais quoi c'est trop
mignonne gros bobos
[Applaudissements]
c'est la nouvelle coqueluche des réseaux
sociaux csn number one franchement cette
vidéo il ya six ans je crois déjà pas
citoyen boîte six ans la famille qu'ils
ont aujourd'hui et est bien mayombo
c'est une ne l'abatte la patinoire
c'est le nouveau est alors le regard et
non mais alors que débute une tournée
internationale le 27 mars prochain
ah oui oui franchement je ne vois pas
pousser la chaussée et par hectare paris
on m'a dit oui que tu voulais danser
oui a pas de souci mais cela pourrait
voler
c'est trop contente toi merci merci
manoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marché de noël
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
si tu avais une personne avec qui tu
pourrais danser sur tour de table ce
serait qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écriture soit hissé comme vidéos
gagnantes heures francis reddy n'a pas
lancé sa vidéo c'est vrai que kelly
c'est quoi elle est trop bien en plus
mal généralement choisi une petite
musique pour se réveiller on met une
autre piste préférée des sonneries des
choses comme ça et lui bah c'est plutôt
spécial je vous laisse regarder
waouh c'est bien c'est carré cé carré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette vidéo je vois là je pense que tu
sais tout c'est toutes ces vidéos sont
exceptionnelles il céderait aucune
d'entre elles n'arrivent sincèrement un
déficient à la cheville monsieur gbagbo
il est ambassadeur de l'eau rapide de
l'affairé était partie du produit oem
africaine sera présent lors du match om
psg le 22 mars au vélodrome et j se
répète donc je te ferai un bisou
leicester à merci react même à moi je
suis accro sial de revoir